Uh, wait a second.
Yes, Steve!
Whoa, nobody makes fun of my dance! That is our dance!
He's waiting. Wait a second.
Lunch break!
Okay, we're back from lunch.
Alright, I'm tired of all these interruptions.
Let's battle!
Be quiet!
Then we will, okay?
She's been laying there for half a-
Oh, okay.
Come on, this battle is boring.
Why isn't she fighting back?
Oh, another interruption.
Just battle!
Ooh, nice one.
Ooh, did you hear something?
No, I didn't hear something.
Who said that? I heard something.
Just battle with-
Nice one!
Cadoc hardly hits. I mean, um, uh,
Cadoc, you gotta
concentrate a little better.
Try to hit her.
Isn't she going to use her last attack?
It's time to-
Back her!
Oh, gosh.
Watch out! She's using the Mimic attack!
She'll use all of your attacks back on you!
Use the Hyper Beam!
No, no, no, don't!
I'm a good copycat, aren't ya?
Bite her, Cadoc!
Copy that part.
Use Confusion!
A wire's broke.
Oh, I just used Confusion.
Oh, I feel dizzy.
Me no dizzy.
I feel dizzy.
She's so annoying!
Use that Ice Ray on her
to freeze her!
She told me not to play with ice!
Super Confusion!
It's off, you idiot!
It is?
Yes! She's going to use Shiny attack!
What's Shiny?
She should've been- From Bunny Ears!
Stupid Shiny attack!
It's making me weak!
Yeah, that's good, you know.
For you.
Uh-huh.
That's all.
She just turned it on!
She turned on playtime!
Stop it!
Playtime! You guys are weak!
Don't battle! Destroy them!
Get you!
I called on the Barang to attack you
until you're destroyed.
Can you tell me, like,
what's that?
She's knocked out!
Use your most powerful attack!
Destroy her!
Make sure she doesn't fire her most powerful attack!
It's the Hundred Acre Pickle Top first!
Yeah!
Try to hit me!
Boing!
Now you try!
Hey, what's that you got in your mouth?
Baby Ella's bunny ears!
You didn't hurt me!
Shoot him with the fastest weapon you got!
You're so slow.
I've got Baby Ella's bunny ears!
Super Punch!
It's hardly hurt, but they're institution!
That's what Tiggers do! Destroy the enemy!
Super Duper Loopy Looper Alley Looper!
Attacking him!
Boing!
Wait a second! I gotta rest!
Into my eye!
Go to sleep!
Super Kick! I have failed!
Body Slam! No, no, no, no!
Sleep with the Super Hyper Sleeperette!
They keep knocking me out with
bothering sleep attacks!
Ugh! Smack Roll Splat!
To me!
How are we ever going to get him in time?
You never will,
Makuta!
Because I am the strongest
of all
the Hundred Acre Wood Gang!
Hehe!
Time for a Super Attack!
Oh no! I have failed!
Super Speed Attack!
I have failed!
Stick!
Watch out!
He's got the Super Climb Attack!
I know!
That's not good enough!
You're going to have to do something like this!
He flew like 12 feet!
My ears!
I can fight better than this!
How pretty it is!
I can still scrape you!
These aren't working for me!
Piglet now!
Fusion's wearing off!
Fusion Attack!
Maybe Jess!
Wait a second!
Oh! Here's a sandwich!
Attack her, Nui-Jaka!
What are you doing?
Fusion!
All it does is make you dizzy!
Now you can attack me!
Block Screen!
Block Screen is not working!
Because I'm a rolly-polly!
Now who's the idiot?
Use the Hyper Beam on her!
You Chinese Idiot!
Air from China!
Chinese food!
If you were smart, you'd use it on me!
Yeah, whatever.
Hey! Look at this!
Look!
Thanks!
Now!
Battle her!
Hyper Beam!
Oh no! Make sure she doesn't use her powerful attacks!
Like Hyper Supernova Pringles
or Big Bashy Big Pringles Bash!
Hyper
Super Super
pressure this!
This is annoying!
Yuanya you fat!
Haha!
I shouldn't give her that idea!
Big Bashy Pringles Bash!
I made the Pringles Rayign stop!
She's not really..
battling at all!
Get rid of her! Use her!
I think somebody's coming that I don't like at all.
Um, oh boy, that's a bad day.
I'm not going to make you feel any better.
I'm going to suck all the color out of you.
Crayon.
Hey, okay, it's all colored.
You even colored yourself.
Pretty Amy.
Use electric beam.
Blocked it.
My tail is flaming.
I'm going to use a fire attack.
Chop that tail off.
I'm going to send in an evil copy of Piglet.
Evil Piglet.
A message.
Oh no, that was the real Tigger.
Happy day.
Oh no, if they figure out what I'm planning, I'm doomed.
Evil Tigger, go get that message.
Happy day.
I will obey your commands, master.
I'll go get that message.
Boing, boing, boing.
Hey, Johnny.
I've got the message.
Lonely sandwich.
Wow.
See, he asked you how the birds work.
I don't know why.
But I figured he was going to get it.
Okay, so I think it's okay.
And then you're playing Friday night.
The high school, right?
Draft in the water.
It's a Saturday.
Fire in the sky.
You have to find it at the door.
Some power.
It's Gatsarika.
Attack her.
Punch buggies.
And Barry.
You touch me.
I'll squeeze her if you touch me.
Touch him.
When I squeeze, she slips out.
I like soap.
Not do that.
You're supposed to.
I put them.
Defy myself.
That stupid thing tripped me.
Piper beam.
We have to battle 40 more seconds.
You, Makuta.
Toe hung up first.
Don't you know?
Just to destroy you, Makuta.
Use it first.
Eeny, meeny, moe.
Catch a tiger by his toe.
If you have it, let him go.
Eeny, meeny, meeny, moe.
My mother says to you, pick the very best one.
And you are it.
Vehicle activated.
Get back on.
To battle without the Voxor vehicle.
But I'm a match for you.
If a Voxor can do this to a Batarang, imagine what an Exo-Tele can do.
Oh, I can't even think of that.
Well, I'm protected.
Hey, I knocked off somebody's mask.
Did you hear it?
Boom, boom.
Four times.
Now can you get me off?
Sure.
Cool.
One more time.
Can I use your mask a minute?
Sure.
Mask of strength.
Here you go.
Thanks.
Pick the Voxor now.
Okay.
Voxor.
Too much.
I have failed.
Voxor can't protect you.
The Voxor cannot be used until the next Tohunga.
Mask back on.
It's time for the Tohunga.
For the Tarana.
Yeah!
I'm going to heal myself.
Look, look, look.
My mask won't fall off for another two times.
Whatever.
Lucky jabs.
I'm just going to tear you up anyway.
Just to take you down.
Yeah!
Boing, boing, boing.
I'll get in the Exo-Tel.
Just wait a second.
We're ready to battle.
I haven't battled in a while.
That's your fault.
Maybe I can take his weak spot out with this cloth.
Spot out with this cloth.
I'm going to take a little break.
Anua, you're boss for a few minutes.
I'm going to use my mask a couple more times.
I'm trying to shred.
He's going to be challenging us.
I'm going to do something that's going to make them really mad.
No.
Whatever.
Special seeing.
That's what I like to call it.
Special vision.
Yeah, that's a good word.
Stop with the chit-chat.
Let's get moving.
Hey, I can't put it on.
It's all messed up.
My head came off.
There we go.
Num-nums.
Exo-Tel's abilities are formidable.
But your powers are no match for mine.
They're smart, huh?
It renders my elemental abilities.
So I'm going to have to use it later.
I'm going to have to use it later.
Yeah, it renders you obsolete.
Ready to battle.
Call.
To revenge.
To avenge Lewa.
Yeah!
Face me, you idiot.
You're losing your style.
I want a challenge from the real Toa.
The Toa Nuva.
You're saying I'm not a challenge just because the Exo-Toa have just come in and you want
to battle them?
Why do you think I'm not a challenge?
You are rendered obsolete.
Get out of here.
I'm angry.
I'm reading the stuff.
Good.
Who's out of here?
The next challenger.
It's the Toa Hunga.
The Toa Raga.
We're going to battle all together.
And then Makuta and Call.
Oah...
The box orb vehicle again.
Is he supposed to be battling?
I'm out of here.
Put down!
My knight doing it.
I shouldn't have told her that.
Dang, that hurts.
We're going to get ya.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to get us now because we're really strong.
The clutch didn't work.
I don't have a choice.
use comments that feels like somebody threw a snowball in my face
toa time yeah give me a new mask because i threw mine
all the way across the battlefield what should i do
get him up from under get her sit on the ice and it's crooked hey i
can't push it all the way over boing well duh i did connection
you're as smart as a rock huh what'd you say anything mike
you can talk to me aren't you gonna attack i'm taking a
rest can somebody fetch me a body no
biting myself my old body this is my new body
are you gonna eat i want to bite your leg looks like a chicken leg
can you okay collections of different masks
that was annoying he's pretty good stupid copaca thingies
wait and gently then pull hard earth to conrad
weak spots crooked i'm smoking a cigar
kids don't smoke i'm gonna do
anything ever lollipop feel in the weak spot anymore it's kind of like
be um this is good but this way i'll never be able to let go of your arm
if i don't get my weak spot back in hey i never thought of that yeah because
you're as dumb as a block of wood hey that's even worse than me i'm
smarter than i know myself that's freaky i took his other arm
well i took all of the water getting kind of boring getting boring
i want to get off i know he doesn't come alive and run back
the top of the world yeah i need to transform into myself
you don't have a head yet yeah now i do
my hand's four did i just do that you're annoying
this thing doing in my hand oh god what's his name
i have failed you gotta fail you failed oh my god and the rest of them i got your
hand
I am the wise Vakama.
Opposite of you.
You're stupid.
Kill her.
I'm not.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
This is mine.
Box or vehicle, come to us.
Dang it.
It's right past you.
It can't hit a Tohunga, but it can hit us.
I'm already waiting.
Get ready.
I'm already telling you out.
No.
Tear this off.
In the box or vehicle around me.
No.
Why don't I kick you?
I like being a soccer ball.
Stuff.
That's where we found her.
Where's McDonald's?
I'm going to get your mask.
So tiny Anua.
Ask him telekinesis.
Yeah.
Good thing I've got friends and family to help me when the tide turns against me.
Give me safer than that.
Give me box or vehicle.
Get him down first before he hurts you.
Transforming thingy.
I'm going to grab your mask.
I don't know how long this is going to take.
It's not like the mask can fire hyper beams.
No.
The box or vehicle does it.
With the mask.
Is it okay if I give the box or my staff the amount that I did?
Sure.
You guys are so funny.
I wish I was as funny as you.
I want to be like you.
Hurry.
Don't do two.
No, two.
I mean.
Get back in here.
I mean, this baloney sandwich.
Happy baloney sandwich.
No.
That's the universal war.
I mean, yeah, that's what it is, but I'm not showing you it cuz it's evil. I demand a refund
Nobody in the city none of us actually ever talk. Yeah
Okay, you can fit on your top who will protect you from the bad rag. Oh, no, he won't slash up
See please sit now I want it I can give it to Gallop
Did you do that? I want to keep I am a servant of Akuma. You do not want to do it. He is Harlow
And with my special staff, I will slash you to bits
You didn't face me once not hold it. No, no, look for his mask. Look for his back right now. Don't bother me
I'm trying to find um the comments back. I'll leave the real one can bring him back. Let's search over here
Dare you I will tear you to shreds
laurie
Gave him better new body. I'ma took the crime. I took his spirit with him
We'll try to search for um his crime. Oh, that's right. I have failed
Before we find any more of the karma
Because his spirit blew off with the Karna. He'll never win again. It's doing aren't you gonna help?
I'm not used to helping the drama
Well, I got a car on my face. Gotcha. Yeah
Thanks guys
I used my staff lose it. I've ever seen before careful with it an interesting
Maybe we'll study that the lab that the other one out, you know what just happened. I will speak with the new club
No, you don't wanna study it with a rock. Oh because the title that says
Belongs to Tana called no pricks. I think it says move on. I'm on we get a very t I'm a very earnedconscious
a very but flavor
I always beat you Makuta, except in the first time we met, well, the second time actually.
That's the way we found the Bohrok.
Something like creatures that come out of something or something.
Exotope.
Prophecy 26.
The Exotope.
My turn.
My Exotope.
Eat me if you have to.
This is a weak spot.
Raptor Rocket.
Aim for his mask.
Grab the mask.
Yeah, that burned the Exotope's foot.
I got some bait here that, ooh, shouldn't have said that.
It's a jelly.
Now you can have it.
It was just bait for him.
You can have it.
What are you doing?
The Exotope.
Are you sure about that, Cat-Ock?
Let's use the ones that were already with me.
It's different.
Like, I have a different type of...
Plants or something.
Do you have electricity?
I always wanted electricity.
Electricity's cool.
How do you power?
But you gotta be in the Exotope to use this chronic.
Okay.
We'll take care of that.
After my turn, it'll be your turn.
The Exotope's foot.
Get me your sword.
You can have my arm.
No.
The Exotope.
You can be shield.
So, Gally.
Shield.
It's funky.
Well, I can't do it.
I still didn't take the gravity power off a Cat-Ock.
You can get up.
No, I can't, you idiot.
Hey, I just did.
Thanks.
You're a real pal.
What'd I do?
But you have electric power.
Yay!
Hey, it didn't affect me, because I'm already electric.
You're splashing his teeth onto my leg further.
My mask is in my foot.
Storage area.
Do this one with it.
I'd rather fit anywhere.
I'm going to change my mask.
Ah, just like old times, huh?
Just the old red mask.
Take that dog.
No.
I'm a criminal.
Use your skin marker.
Blue Tofu and the red tofu.
I'm going to jam my sword down your throat.
Both throats.
Hey, nobody cut.
Oh, I almost stole my sword.
Hey, yeah.
Swallow.
Yeah, change mask.
Oh, the wand.
Yeah, but I mean, you just.
I'm just normally that fast.
Oh, hunger.
Kaiyito.
Yup.
I trapped him.
Hey, you.
Suicide.
Get those extra masks on his back.
Yes.
Okay, there's nothing.
Send to the left.
No, no, no, no.
Spam.
Why don't you use beans?!
Something.
What?
Boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boing
Boing boing boing boing boing boing boing boin
There's berries popping up everywhere!
Boing boing boing boing boing
Chars up!
They're going to charge up!
The watermelon makes me charge up!
No pancakes!
Use Confusion!
Use Super Confusion!
Well, Kaito, I've seen you were a hero before, but not a kamai.
Yeah, you saw her the second...
The third time we met, actually.
Yeah.
And my head's turning blue!
Haha, that doesn't affect me, you leaf.
It was Matt.
I got it.
I've won the challenge.
I'm gonna smash you.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm gonna slash your tail off.
Kai-Kiki! Kai-Kiki!
Kai-Kiki!
Look at that!
That's an iron saw.
That's explosive.
Kick.
Indy sword you got there.
It's kind of hard to slay it.
It's pretty heavy.
Oh, yeah.
Scoot, scoot, scoot.
Scared.
My head's crooked.
Oh, what the heck.
You just ate lots of strawberries.
Slap, slap, slap.
Do you want me to look at my trophy
and shine it in their eyes?
No, that's okay.
Ooh, maybe I can attach these masks to my hand.
They're strength masks.
This is the hand that I can attach
infected masks to.
And then they can't affect me,
but I can still use their power.
Super strength!
I have super strength!
Kai-Kiki's getting boring features.
I'll just do this, and this,
and this, and this,
and this.
I'm almost knocked out.
Nuva.
Not too bad.
Looks like you aren't smart enough.
Get ready.
Put on all your armor.
See it.
It allows good people around you
to use the same power.
But it's too bad you don't have
gold masks.
Hmm.
Eventually I think we'll get them.
But I have a friend who lives in Oman
who might be more powerful than me.
But who cares?
They're gonna join the super family at some time.
Which are they?
Hmm. They're a relative of the Bohrok.
Hmm. Are they the Bohrok?
No, they're not.
Ready. Just hold on.
Activating swords.
I'm gonna slash you up.
I'm not used to battling like this.
I'm too good for you, Makuta.
Boing!
You can't get my mask off, cause you're too stupid.
I call on
Prophecy 27!
Totoa!
I'm gonna take off my armor.
Steal it before he gets it back.
No, no you can't, Makuta.
It's got good power in it.
It won't work.
Who cares?
I'm telling you.
Believe me, I'm a good person.
I won't lie.
I'm like you, cause I'm polite enough.
Get it.
It'll make me look a lot bigger.
You think you're powerful enough to defeat me now?
What am I saying these days?
Deacons don't play with sharp stuff.
Activate!
I gotta use another mask.
Thingy's off.
What thingy?
They say you don't know what it is.
Ooh, I can see your other side.
Mwaka's eating tires.
Stop that!
So, we're gonna get a little break, but
he's really strong.
Hmm.
You read me like a book.
We're in for a fight today.
That's all you say, Roger.
Darn it, darn it, darn it.
Whenever your mom says,
I'm gonna give you a hundred dollars,
and then you go, darn it,
and then she doesn't give it to you.
Stop mocking me!
I'm not mocking you, Mwaka. I'm just making fun of you.
Stop making fun of me.
You don't even know what mocking is.
Yes, I do.
What's two plus two?
Four. Four.
Hey! Four.
You're too annoying. You're too annoying.
I'm stupid. You're stupid.
I should've waited.
Who cares? I'm gonna battle.
I'm gonna knock him dead.
Yup.
Yeah.
Which mask should I wear first?
My mirror nuva? My kakama nuva?
Or my normal?
I'll wear my normal.
Oh no, that's the strength mask.
Get ready.
Oh no, you don't.
Hey, my mask! You're annoying.
I lost it already.
Good job, Gaddock.
Now you can't do that to us.
Oh no.
Lithia dear. Lithia dear.
Did you find your gear? I didn't. It's in my case.
It's too powerful for you.
You're electric.
You're weak like Makuta.
I could destroy you in one swipe.
And why don't I do that now?
You're gonna destroy me?
You'll be destroyed after this.
Nuva!
The stupid shield is fighting me.
Pass it.
That's a really powerful power.
I'll get that before she can.
The shield. The shield's a challenge?
Gaddock, that shield's a challenge to you?
Then I can't imagine what Kopaka Nuva's like.
I didn't know that.
Something happened.
I don't know what happened.
Who's laughing?
I'm gonna go surfing.
Why isn't she talking?
I mean, she isn't having an engaging conversation.
Put these things on.
Oh no.
She's gonna move too fast for us.
I'm too good.
Better not make me mad, cause I'm gonna get ya!
Boing.
Boing. Boing.
My weak spot fell out.
I'm making a pizza monster.
Now there is
too much
for me.
Once he's done.
Look at all those masks.
I got the most masks.
You said that again.
I know that.
How do you know it?
Because I do.
Shut up!
Who said that?
I did.
I'm gonna use my kakama mask first thing.
I have two of them.
Isn't that cool?
You have a better idea.
Guess what I can do.
What?
I can turn my grabber claws into a koly ball.
That sentence was all broken up.
What did you say?
I can turn my hands into a koly ball.
You've never been on Mata Nui?
It's just kind of like a soccer ball.
Only faster.
More powerful.
Cooler.
Activate cool.
I'm more durable.
Hey, give me your mask.
You're too annoying.
I hate you.
That doesn't affect me.
And that wasn't my strongest pick either.
Where's my mask that I lost?
There it is.
I'll have to put it in my case.
All these delays.
Did you see that? Did you see that?
I knocked the mask off.
With this.
Mist.
My hand fell off.
Strength mask.
You'll feel the power of the Toe Nuva team.
You think I'm a challenge.
You think I'm not a challenge.
Well.
This is my weakest kick, kids.
Do you want me to go a little bit stronger?
Uh.
Yes.
It came off, but I can get it back on after that kick.
Wanna go again?
On your back.
Hey, buddy.
What was that?
Super kick.
I'm gonna take your weak spot out so you're not annoying me anymore.
Last one.
Did you see my gear?
I need to find it.
This is what I do.
You think you can beat me just because you're a Toe Nuva.
In fact, Makuta, I think I can.
I think I can.
Catch him!
I have failed.
Your normal one.
Use your one other one.
The other one makes me look like I don't have a nose at all.
Yeah, there's a nose.
It kinda looks like you don't have a nose at all.
Don't mind the weak spot.
Put your armor on first.
I am.
Because it's more important than the weapon.
The old one?
Yeah.
Oh, he's good at that.
Ooh, time to annoy the Rahi.
Mwaka and Kanra, actually.
Let's annoy them.
Line up your masks over here when you're not using some of them.
Okay.
I only have two.
Oh, what the heck. You've got good defense.
And plus, you've got the power to draw them back if you lose them too much.
I love that.
Except a little faster because you're a Toa Nuka.
Yep.
And it kind of hurts your shin.
Hey, it looks like our legs have little capes.
I think they do.
They stop above the ankle.
I can't get this dumb mask off.
Okay, I'm going to transform myself.
Maybe you could try.
I need something.
Hey, there's mine.
Except when the hotline rings.
But I hate that too because I'm awoken from my slumber.
Why do always really powerful people or like really powerful evil people say,
Why do you wake at me from my slumber?
It's weird.
Makoto, why do they do that?
Put my mask back on.
That was too boring.
I wish we had gold masks.
I think they're going to be coming out.
I think there's some at the Toa store.
I bet they're expensive.
He was awesome when he kicked that rock and knocked the mask off just like that.
My mask, it's falling in the lava.
Why do you have a concussion on your head?
Now it's even deeper.
Hey Gally, watch this.
It doesn't affect me.
Ugly.
Get away from my beautiful masks.
I say ugly.
I want to get away from my beautiful masks.
Hooks too on your axes.
No, I mean like this.
Hey, thanks.
Heya.
You remember your old hooks?
Well, yeah.
Well, now you got four of them
and plus you got a sharp edge.
And it's an axe.
Oh, jeez.
Don't make me.
This battle needs some music.
It won't be for long.
Just for a couple minutes.
Yes.
I cannot battle correctly.
I had to run through my attic to get it out.
You did?
Yeah.
I didn't know you had an attic.
I'm starting it up.
I got too much charged up.
Find pieces.
So I can put it back on.
Pickles are good for your kids.
They cut the grease.
And remember kids,
don't try this at home.
Yup.
And especially don't mistreat an oyster.
An oyster farm.
Oyster farm?
Yeah.
Makuta looks a little different
since the last time we battled.
He looks dumber.
I think he looks, like,
different because Nui Rama
is attached to his thigh.
And he's got those little tickling guns.
No, they're not tickling guns.
He turns getting hit with it.
Hey, it sounds like I got wet feet.
Bogged from your water attack.
Burned to, like, toast
because of your fire feelings.
Huh?
I can get more powerful than he normally is.
Now I can move.
You can't close this up.
I can't bite him.
Because you don't have your weak spot, dodo brain.
And besides,
like this.
Are there any other batteries
I can take care of?
I think she has to wait
in the dentist's room
because I think her dentist
can use my mask only one more time.
Recover.
How dare you
do that to me.
I just switch them back and forth.
Um, what do we do now?
Oh, Nui Rama.
It's kind of boring.
I got masks.
More like devil bless you.
God would.
Wait, why doesn't he get zoomed in?
Blade mode.
He likes it.
Just attack Nui Rama on a daily basis.
Just ignore him.
Ignore whatever he says.
Did you hear something?
I think I heard
my sword hitting Waka's brain.
Like there is one.
Luckily for me,
Conrad doesn't have a brain.
Ooh, check this out.
What's wrong with that?
Your head's hollow, isn't it?
Waka's brain is a walnut,
but Conrad doesn't have one.
Super jab.
I can throw him in at people.
Hey,
he's a walnut.
I can throw him at cars and make a hole in the window.
But don't try that at home, kid.
Trouble.
They say, shh.
Bad peoples.
Last attack.
What do I do?
Go on.
Turn me into a spring.
That's all I got to say.
It's Stacy.
Okay, thank you.
Get off me.
With the bag.
Stuff.
Beams and stuff.
Stop knocking me.
My hair.
Are you supposed to...
Mata Nui bug.
Oh, no. Don't let her get...
Fuzzball.
But I do have this killer insect.
Where'd she go?
That's a cell phone.
Right here.
I'm going to get it out.
By yourself.
And then devour
Sparky. He's so pathetic.
Oh, no.
You'll never get my weak spot out.
You're not a challenge.
Awake yet?
You don't know anyone
that does this entire battle.
What did you say?
What'd you say?
What?
She's got psychic powers. Watch out.
I didn't...
No, don't fight.
You'll have to get the bug spray out.
But I do have...
Oh, boy.
She's got to lose some time.
She's going to use her final attack.
It's Nell.
Stacy's mother.
And Doctor Senora's wife.
She's weak.
Beams. Idiot.
Electric beams.
She doesn't make up names or anything.
Like the Toadoo.
Let me get you.
She's got a bunch.
I want to battle Doctor Senora.
Is that a powerful attack?
Oh, no.
It's a Doctor Senora.
Why didn't you want to get up earlier?
You're going to need help.
This guy is so powerful.
It's you.
You get out of here, Carl.
You've been sleeping all the time.
But Makoto won't be returning.
Reveal my true appearance to Doctor Senora.
Huh.
Is it a ducky?
Clank.
What's that piece of junk?
It's my body.
It's more powerful than the one
you see before you.
You mean you're more powerful than yourself?
No, the bigger one, you idiot.
I can take the body
of anything my Krana attached to.
Oh, in fact,
Doctor Senora, I am the Krana
you see before you.
The Wheel of Evil.
But you are so weak.
We've destroyed you so many times.
Why do you keep
thinking you'll defeat us,
Doctor Senora?
To win, I only need
three factors.
Chaos, destruction,
and war.
I only need one more
factor.
I already have two of them.
Destruction, chaos.
Now what do you think I might need?
Huh? Universal War?
Ha!
Exactly.
Hmph.
You're smarter than that.
Sometimes your intelligence surprises me,
Doctor Senora.
You see before you
the spirit of destruction.
I am the spirit of destruction,
Doctor Senora.
The reason you cannot destroy me
is because
that I am the spirit of destruction.
If you destroyed me,
in fact, you can't destroy me
because if you destroyed me,
you couldn't destroy anything else.
Yeah, but then you'd be
helpless too.
But I'd be destroyed.
Evil could run amok
and you wouldn't be able to stop us.
Yes, but you couldn't
destroy us.
We could threaten you.
Dying is
not
destruction.
We could take you
and destroy all of you.
We couldn't destroy your villages
or anything like that.
Shut up. Let's battle.
No, no. I'm not battling right now.
Let's let my
little friends take care of it
first.
Get up. Get up. You're up first.
Dream low.
But that's what you think.
I did special training and I am a
Super Saiyan 4.
Let's battle.
I'm not gonna show any mercy on you.
It doesn't affect me.
You cannot destroy me.
A cursed mass.
Nui Jougi, go.
You shouldn't be letting these
so-called servants
battle for you.
They are
so worn out because you
made them work.
Go, Mwaka.
Conra. Insignificant
little
person into the ground.
Stay back.
Music. Music,
please.
If you don't destroy me
this time, which I doubt
you will escape and cause
havoc beyond your wildest
universal war,
I will prepare it
in hiding for one
year. Well,
Makuta, let's end this.
I got him. Let me finish him off
now. Hold him still.
Snakey, get in there.
Suck his soul out.
At least they're not harmless.
At least they're not harmful now.
Just...
fall.
This is it, Makuta.
Well, the spirit of
destruction meets the weakest
person in the world. Dr. Cinear,
you are the most dim-witted
I have met in the cosmos
in my travels.
You're going to be traveling
to
the great beyond when I'm done
finished with you. Fighter mode.
Fighter mode.
Or walking mode.
Music, please.
Destruction.
You dare face the spirit of
destruction?
Don't move.
Transform.